j'ai déjeuné avec Renaud l'autre jour il
c'est lui qui a dit cette phrase
magnifique à propos de la naissance d'
d'un de ses enfant de sa femme lui dit
si tu veux tu peux booire un verre de
vin et lui a répondu cette phrase
magnifique il a dit un verre c'est trop
et 12 c'est pas
assez c'est exactement ça la dépendance
c'est ça ouais c'est ça c'est mais
est-ce que pour vous vous qui avez été
Benjamin toi est-ce que tu tu as
toujours été dans l'excès ou bien c'est
c'est la séle je suis ex
mais je pense que la célébrité c'est pas
la célébrité c'est les gens qui ont un
talent immense je ne connais pas une
star vraiment digne de ce nom qui n'est
pas alors pas forcément un vis mais un
excès quelque part c'est soit soit c'est
l'alcool soit c'est la drogue soit c'est
les femmes c'est l'argent mais je ne
connais pas une personne qui est
vraiment réussi à un niveau exceptionnel
qui n'est pas quelqu alors je pas pas
envie de dire déviancetion une addiction
une quel un petit grain de folie parce
que si on n pas ce petit grain de folie
on n pas une St on n pas unique moi j'ai
eu la chance de côyer pas il y a pas de
star
ici y a vous il y a Jean-Marie
excusez-moi Jean-Marie est un immense
humoriste et Jean-Marie pour merci tu
rebois quelque chose moi moi j'is moi le
vôtre le sport la vous vous votre vous
votre votre votre excès à vous c'est
votre excès à vous c'est je pense qu'il
est dans le sport je pense que vous
pouvez pas mais je pense que vous êtes
êt question intellig V je je fini 2
secondes monsieur deor ouais et après
moi dans ma famille il y avait des gens
qui étaient des vrais stars ils étaient
les deux ils avaient un P au casque bah
oui ma grand-mère elle est quand elle a
eu un Oscar Hollywood c'est une immense
actrice elle a quand même sombré
copieusement dans l'alcool et quand à
Mont temps il était obsédé par les
femmes donc je et après j'ai rencontré
d'autres gens que je ne citerai pas mais
je ne connais pas une immense star qui
n'est pas un petit une petite dose de
folie il y en a pas intéressant oui ce
qui est très intéressant c'est tous les
chanteurs qui tombent dans la dépression
ou dans la drogue c'est et c'est la
question j'ai à Jean-Marie quand tu fais
un stade de France qu' y a 80000
personnes t'envoie une décharge
d'adrénaline d'amouroui bien s une Dr
chez toi avec tuas ta femme qui dit tu
as ramené le pain enfin Justin Bieber a
dit derrière même jet Arman a dit
derrière tu supportes plus et du coup tu
vas compenser avec des artifices comment
tu comment tu reprends une vie normale
quand tu fais des tournées comme ça tu
veux pas moi j'ai pris un peu d'avance
sur le Stade de France j'étais mort de
peur 48 he avant et le jour même j'avais
déjà passé l'obstacle c'est-à-dire au
moment où tout le monde me disait mais
ça va je disais oui ça va c'est le jour
où toute mon équipe était comme ça le
jour de l'événement mais moi je l'avais
déjà traversé mais qu tu vis des tes
shoot comment après tu vis une vie
normale euh après j'ai pris mon petit
déjeuner trois biscotes un petit peu de
de beurre salé et puis ça a été très
très bien je l'ai j'ai pas voulu un seul
journaliste à mon Stade de France c'est
voulu faire le truc tout seul et puis de
je donc je l'ai très bien bien digérer
j'ai tout le monde m'a dit que c'était
impossible à faire j'ai réussi mon coup
et et ça s'est passé sans sans accro
sans vague j'ai je n'ai pas été submergé
si tu veux par par mon mon exploit Marco
toi c'est c'est c'est moi je suis moi je
depuis depuis un an que je suis connu je
te dire la vérité et je bois un petit
verre le soir mais on a je pense que
tout le monde a un problème c'est quand
tu es connu tu es invité partout ou déjà
à la base tu es invité partout mais toi
tu vas non attends je t' pas dit fais
pas comme de nor sir je t'ai pas dit j'y
vais je t'ai dit tu es invité par ouis
mais moi j'aime moi j'aime pas la maison
ah ouais donc j'aime bien être dehors
j'ai horreur de la maison tu sais quand
tu fais 7 p je placard et tu veux plus
être enfermé moi je vois la maison je
tremble je s à 5h du matin et je rentre
à 4h hein ah ouis c'est une façon de
parler
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça qu'il a dit ah
bon et la vérité franchement quand bon
on n'est pas au stade de Bigard Bigard
c'est waouh c'est W non mais pour de
vrai c'est wou on s'est rencontré
plusieurs fois dans les restaurants tu
tapais du vin comme j'ai jamais vu j'ai
dit non mais attends il y a rien de il y
a rien et puis moi je me suis dit ben il
a raison le mec il a raison il s'éclate
et moi je pense que un mec qui s'arrête
tu peux pas faire la morale à quelqu'un
déjà si lui il a pas décidé d'arrêter
quelque chose tu peux faire ta morale tu
peux faire n'importe qui le docteur il
peut te dire tu vas mourir tu dis bon la
dernière cigarette et tu la continues tu
tu peux pas t'arrêter donc quand tu bois
tu es mort pourquoi tu as pas envie de
t'arrêter donc aujourd'hui moi aussi je
bois un verre le soir pour manger avec
je kiffe je me détends et j'oublie tout
ce qui se passe parce que c'est très dur
qu'est-ce qui arrive à tout le monde qui
est là ne croyez pas que c'est pour moi
ne croyez pas que d'être une vedette il
y a des trucs positifs énormément mais
il y a beaucoup de négatif énormément de
négatif ah ouais c'est vrai non
énormément je te le promet qu'
énormément de négatif c'est quoi le
négatif qui te vient l'esprit tu tu
avances plus tu sais moi par exemple moi
je veux j'été j'ai pas de banque je vais
pour me faire une banque le mec il fait
sty de pas me reconnaître et je lu dis
vas-y dis-moi carrément si tu vas me
jeter ou si tu vas me prendre et il me
dit mais monsieur Mouli non je veux pas
vous prendre alors je dis pourquoi tu
fais perdre mon temps bah ça c'est pas
la notoriité c'est parce que tu as fait
7 ans de prison mais il est bête mais si
on suis pas mais si suis pas connu je
suis pas connu mais attends si je suis
pas connu il connait monsieur mou lui
oui ou pourquoi tu
B pourquoi tu es bête pas F F mais
pourquoi il est bête il a la question et
la réponse si on con si toi tu me
connais pas tu vas dire bonjour monsieur
ou c'est tout tu maintenant tu me dis
bonjour Comment Marco mou donc ça parce
que je connais et comment tu me connais
parce que je viens là ouais donc voilà
c'est tout c'est
[Rires]
simple vous pourrais m'énerver à tout
moment c'est incroyable on parlait juste
de célébrité estce que la célébrité
pousse au vice Raymon toi qui est devenu
célèbre non mais c'est vrai non non mais
moi j'aurais répondu non à cette
question là la célébrité stovis non elle
c'est partout partout il y a de l'alcool
partout il y a des partout il y a il y a
des histoir de cul c'est tout le monde
c'est tous les gens sauf que sauf que la
célébrité elle a cet avantage c'est
qu'il a il y a tout le temps des gens
qui vont te tendre la main quand tu es
dans l'alcool qui va te tendre la main
parce que tu es connu il y a quelqu'un
qui va te te sortir un moment de là ou
alors pas puis le
fric donne toutes les possibilité voilà
quelqu'un qui boit chez lui tout seul et
qui est dans l'alcooliste parfois il est
tout seul tout seul la célébrité c'est
c'est médiatisé c'est
visible les gens dans dans la vie de
tous les jours c'est pas visible et tu
le sais pas la célébrité avec les ré ça
et voilà Marco tu préférais quand tu
étais connu ou pas connu euh alors pour
mon boulot je préféis quand j'étais pas
connu ouis tu
m'étonne pour êre voleur c'est plus
ouais c'est vrai que parce que c'est V
déc quelque part tu VASER Mar non mais
c'est et et là je remonte mes affaires
dans à l'étranger et mais je suis connu
aussi ça y est là ah merde non ça me va
ça me va parce que maintenant je fais
autre boulot ça veut dire que je
m'arrange avec au contraire ça m'amène
beaucoup de choses sur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
instagramç que la célébrité ça ramène
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses ça
veut dire beaucoup de choses ouis j'ai
jeoté je m'arrêter sur n'importe quel
point tu as vu je va t'attaquer après
pas j'ai entendu
Tattaquer ça n'a aucun sens la
célébritéppte du de la saug tu crois
quoi tu crois qu' dit moi c'est du crro
lui il fait non la célébrité ramène
beaucoup de choses bah tu es invité
partout les gens ils veulent faire des
affaires avec toi oui c'est ça tu
dépenses pas une tune tu crois que tu as
refait de CO tu vas en boîte il y a des
bouteilles qui tombent de partout tu dis
combien je te dois tu as pas mar bon ok
j'insiste plus ouais tuas pas honte
j'insiste plus moi je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec Raymond parce que oui
effectivement l'alcool il y en a partout
la drogue il y en a partout donc il y a
pas que les gens célèbres mais il y a un
truc qui est vraiment je trouve très
spécifique de la célébrité c'est le la
particule d'accélération par rapport à
la séduction et par rapport aux filles
ou aux garçons je suis désolée il y a
beaucoup de célébrités qui peuvent avoir
beaucoup plus accès à certaines jeunes
filles ou à certains jeunes garçons qui
n'auraiit pas eu normalement dans leur
condition d'homme exemple kessada
jurisprudence kessada alors là c'est un
cas extrême parce que lui il est en plus
devenu prédateur jurisprudence PPDA
jurisprudence Norman jurisprudence le
footballeur Mendy qui lui tout d'un coup
il a cru que il était bah oui bah il a
été je crois qu'il a quand même il s'est
pas encore jugé c'est là ça va être là
enfin malgré tout il y avait quand même
une panique room chez lui et ramené des
filles donc en fait tu as pas accès à
certaines meufs et tout d'un coup tu es
célèbre tu as des nanas qui par ex il a
toujours été beau gosse non mais c'est
vrai castal non mais c'est vrai dis la
vérité
castal mais je dis franchement tu aurais
eu du succès quand même il est beau
gosse Benjamin faut arrêter il a t é
beau gosse mais un facilitateur
voilà Gill par G oui tu as d
faciliter dégueulasse je v av
arrête une question pour Marco toi tu as
été très très riche est-ce que quand tu
es très très riche tous les gens qui
viennent vers toi deviennent faux est-ce
que tu arrives à sentir excuse-moi tu
parles français ou pas parce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aiouche
dans je dans la fausse note le soufflet
au sultan alors est-ce que les G est-ce
que l'argent induit la fausseté tu vois
que les gens l' en réalité tu l'as tout
le monde devient faux est-ce que toi
avec Cyr tu es entier bah j'espère
l'être ou non franchement comment ça se
fait que tout ce qui dit Cyril tu dis
oui voà stop dis-moi ça et tu as tout
compris la on est souvent en désaccord
sur T lesi une fois as éé en
daccord on parlait d'honnêteté tout à
l'heure et je l'ai pas dit attends je
peux l'allumer ou pas il te donne
unexc il te donne un tu l'exécutes
patron il te dit va on tu tu au milieu
du carrefour tu vas toi aussi hein
excuse-moi on parlait d'honnêteté tout à
l'heure tu te souviens de la
discussion j'ai pas voulu puisque tu me
cherches ouis j'ai pas voulu intervenir
parce que Marco chargé de toi tout à
l'heure tu as parlé d'honnêteté tu te
souviens tu disais à Marco on peut
réussir en étant honnêtei est-ce que
quand tu vends h fois le même
documentaire à C8 de Disney en changeant
[Applaudissements]
tuas les G quii qui comm si tu avais
fait quel chose tu rend comp son t
différent avec un angle différent mais
même çaangle tu sais pas ce que c'est
parce que tu es même pas journaliste ta
carte de presse tues foutu dans le
[Applaudissements]
culégrité av besoin il av
besoin ça va mieux
là toute la
soirée mais le pauvre voilà bon
écoutezoulez avez quelque chose àjouter
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que j'ajoute
non mais tout le monde se moque de lui
sur la place de Paris avec sa petite
société de mais non mais c'est vrai il
il v il vend 10 fois le même document
nous on lui
achète on lu
achète C soyez honnête non mais si on
dit
tout
tu
vois alors attends cy est-ce que cy je
vous pose une seule question vous me
répondez honnêtement est-ce que vous lui
achetez parce qu'il vient chaque année
vous implorez achète-moi TR do que je
sauve ma boîte de production et
attention à ce que vous répondez parce
que j'était là quand il vous a posé la
question il te men du tout il te
men il te men alors que tu l'as
sor c'est vrai tu as raison
laisse cyil répondre et ben tu vas voir
alors pas du
tout le doc Disney a très bien marché
sur
cible est-ce que j'étais déjà impleuré
oui
oui en direct en direct il l' fait en
direct en
direct pour terminer que ma boîte qui
marche si mal comme l'autre con le dit
elle fait tourner 4 CDI et 20 personnes
pendant que tu mets ta petite gueule sur
ces news pour gagner du pognon moi je tu
don du travail à 20 personnes tu dones
du travail à qui
[__] plus le droit parce que moi j'ai
une question vouser
parce pour
pouro
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur les ring du cul qui en vacances et
rien à dire j'ai pas regard sur news
rien à dire qu' s rien
passé
ils ont pris les
[Applaudissements]
RAR par que
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
personnee
tu la honte du documentaire français
documentaire français tu sa
honte c'était carrément ton portrait
tellement on que
toibécile je
t'emmerde toi et ta famille surette
génération sur la
feu laisse-oi laisse-moi l la feuille de
service sur la feuille de service c'est
marqué qu' allit a ce sujet pour que ça
crée un débat
interne calme et
silencieux plî c'est qui ce
plateau là tu as fait du marc Mouli là
là tu as fait du marcouz plus rien à
vous direzé votre sa P c'est qu'ils sont
honnêtes je sais
merci merci les chér en tout cas on voit
je rappelle que la question la question
était la célébrité pour regardez
regardez
le casque
c'est trèsux comm même sans alcool comme
le vis non la folie oui pouvez le voir
je vais peut-être me remettre à
boire j'en peux plus non c'est bon
c'est sympa merci en tout cas ça me fait
plaisir de vous voir comme ça vous allez
êtes quand même quand même po groupe ah
là c'est fini jour ten un jour ils sont
pas fait la bise ou
hier vous le dit tant pis c'est les
enfants j'encule mes
[Applaudissements]
r
PL
l'autreas tenu un jour ben l'autre je
[Applaudissements]
l'encule non mais tu es
malade résolution tu as dit que tu
allais plus avoir d'embrouille avec
personne mais c'est lui qui m'a provoqué
vous rendez compte ce qu'il dit
6 ans c'est moi qui
provoqué la petite fille du guignol
l'autre c'est l'autre con surtout tu es
un con un con de le mot tu nes qu'un con
c'est bon allez calmevous allez merci
vous allez vous retrouver demain et tout
l'important c'est de discuter
l'important c'est discuter je pense je
vous sentez beaucoup mieux tous les deux
moi je me suisou ai qu'avant ça
m'avait la voy très bien la voyante
l'avait dit elle voyait rien pour vous
c'est non après elle m'a même dit pire
pendant la pub non elle dit je pouvais
pas vous dire sera une année un peu
compliqué ça
démarêre 2
janvier